many apps have a common broiler plate it
would be great if there was a way to
reuse infrastructure templates to deploy
multiple services
let's see how kpt helps bob manage this
bob is a lead on the application
development team which is currently in a
crunch
they need to launch 10 apps for an
upcoming deadline
most of the effort is in the common
infrastructure
but each app requires certain
modifications that are hard to manage in
a consistent way
bob's first instinct is to copy and
paste kubernetes manifests between
projects but this has many downsides
manually having to make changes to
copy-pasted code
is time-consuming and error-prone in an
ideal world
bob would be able to define standardized
configuration templates
customize setting for each specific
application
and then modify them all as a unit what
bob needs is packaging
and with deadlines looming he needs it
pronto
bob asks charlie for help who introduces
him to ida a developer on the platform's
team
ida explains the benefits of config as
data
and shows bob how to use templates with
kpt
to reuse customize project broiler plate
which dramatically accelerates bob's
work
kbt is an oss tool for kubernetes
packaging
which uses a standard format to bundle
publish
customize update and apply configuration
manifests
its git plus yaml architecture means it
just
works with existing tools frameworks and
platforms
kpt is built around a config as data
architecture
that bundles up kubernetes resource
configuration
this format is readable for both humans
and machines
and is a source of truth for declarative
platform
the benefit of reading and writing the
package content using standardized data
structures
enables kpt to apply bulk updates
creation and deletion of projects run
user-defined functions to apply custom
behaviors to config files
seamlessly integrate into the kubernetes
infrastructure
and more which is exactly what bob's
team needs
say we wanted to work with kubernetes
examples repositories for demo sake
we could run the kpt package get command
to fetch the entire directory this has a
lot of files
no fear though we can use the kpt
count command to summarize the files in
an easier way to read
you can do a lot more with filtering and
listing resource
in different ways but i want to take a
second to focus on using kpt
to update and validate config files
let's take a look at an example if we
use the kpt
cfg list setter command we can see which
values were able to use the kpt tool
so this package contains three setters
we can use with the kpt
set tool and the current value of the
properties
let's set the number of replicas to
three
now one of the benefits of a tool like
kpt is its ability to use functions to
apply
changes like this on a number of config
files at once
so i urge you to look into the resource
link below for a walkthrough on that
and there you have it with kpt you can
easily create
and customize and compose configuration
packages
while adhering to the configuration as
data philosophy
with this knowledge bob is able to
quickly get his application
spun up in time to meet the deadline so
that's it for kpt
make sure to check out the description
for links to more resources on it
and like and subscribe to the channel
for more videos about google cloud
thanks for watching
you